hello and welcome to the CEO playing mt
Cicero okay with the Kings gambit let's
play for that wiki counter gambit I mean
this at least it shows that we get some
crazy action
okay 22 what is this I can play 94 and
he goes Quincy for I guess okay but g5
is a normal move and I'm threatening 94
now
and Bishop f5 is normal I can also play
night before why not I will see coloring
this playing the deponent 93 okay
on a strange position d 4 okay um III
can't see s discovered i would like to
play c5 but he's got Bishop b5 check
this is a pretty annoying okay I think
I'm taking them
check
I can just take this take this on a
three but it's that good I mean this is
not a good piece on and it's just play
normal development
93 coming up hmm no I don't think so 93
f Bishop to c5 now it's going down 94 or
just going back okay I'm going back I
can play c 5 t for anyway
okay um wow I can't see I can just
attack him g3 that's g5
can push up c5 doesn't it looks really
strange yeah but it's the Kings can bet
that you have those wacky looking things
quite often okay so it keeps f4 covered
I can still go g5 trying to exploit it's
a week coordination g5 is got d for down
don't really see something very powerful
look at six 493 business and maybe my
own son is Keith's got something going I
played this badly pretty awful ok anyway
I'd seem
yeah I know what that is he going to
play made you fire one push up on Cena
it's better developed all of a sudden
now what did i do them I think I didn't
play with a clear enough idea yeah of
course
now I can take a forum no I cannot but
may I can develop the picture finally I
did show no no I just did not at all
react to what's going on here
oh I really hate to lose against this
[ __ ] opening it really is weird
anyway
united four you can probably play under
than a good rookie five million time
warning
yeah strategically default was terrible
but it had a tactical idea
so it was strategically bad because of
this check check let should have taken
with the bloody bishop what the heck
check black forfeits full for the time
oh what the game no I mean I could just
take with the bishop and whatever I mean
okay it was just terrible okay yeah so
Wow I had talked to any license without
ya check ok so I think this is this is
ok I mean maybe this very night before
is better i know i mean black is ok yeah
of course but i couldn't really couldn't
really find something great Jackie
addresses typical blitz move somehow but
I'm getting behind in development yeah
somehow I'm not able to take take stuff
yeah here I'm in trouble it is just too
slow yeah probably i should play 94like
here Knight g4 I was thinking he goes
Queenie true what I have quit be sick
said that I didn't see that at all this
wins for black the engine sensor he has
to take and then okay this is fantastic
of course it's a very strong bishop pair
this is just very slow and I mean he's
winning him he's just winning with all
his act active pieces yeah i blundered
g4 I mean I just blundered this
yeah yeah be sure before SSID I wasn't
my god d for what kind of movies that he
prepares we should be formed and he
allows be sure to be four but yeah I
mean he's winning when you planted
everything back could have taken f3 here
cuz teenage for threatening yeah okay
night takes us rookie to okay it was the
first clear winner and then he played to
check this I can just take with the
bishop I mean check yes I completely
completely can we add game and I didn't
even realize how much download time I
was doesn't help that it's minus seven
hun oh wow okay thanks for watching